Speaker 1: As if we didn't have already.
Five or six things happened this week
that were completely beyond parody. Mike
Pillow. You guys remember Mike Lindell,
the CEO of Mypillow?
Speaker 4: We're doing
a class action lawsuit against all machines.
Speaker 1: Yeah, that guy. He has a new deadline.
And honestly, at this point, is this just a
joke? Because you can even see Steve Bannon
standing in the background. This was at CPAC.
I'm pretty confident over the weekend. Again,
Pillow says the new deadline, it's August
20, August 21. That's like ten, nine, eight,
nine, ten days from now. He says it's going to
happen. We're going to see the biggest change the
country has ever seen. And even though he's put
together, what, 15, 20 different deadlines so far,
none of which have gone anywhere, do people
still believe this? Is it possible someone
is dumb enough to still believe this?
Speaker 4: I'm telling you, after the 20th
and the 21st of August, the aftermath of that,
you're going to you're going to see the biggest
change this country has ever seen. And you're
going to also see judges. I said this before.
Everyone says, Well, Mike, what do you mean, the
judges? You go back a year and a half. Not one
judge looked in evidence except for Antrim County,
Missouri, but he didn't want to rule on it. And
those judges back then, they have families. They
have neighbors, they have grandchildren. They were
afraid. I'm telling you, they were afraid. But
in a year and a half later, after everyone's seen
the destruction of our country, what's it?
What is it? So slow that destruction helped
build the judges? How about those hundred?
If you have 100 people in your company,
you have to take a shot. Become a junkie.
Speaker 1: The question one is, does Steve
Bannon have any idea what pillows talking about?
Question two is, does the crowd stop that?
Speaker 4: Okay, how about how about the judge
in Florida that made the great ruling about the
mail stand on airplane seizure of Roe v Wade? Huh.
Speaker 1: So, listen, if you are still credulous,
believing this guy after the gig a
millionth time that he has pulled this act,
you just want to be taken for a ride. It's sort
of like, take my money. What can I donate to
the audits to give me something
to donate to? This guy has been
first. It was going to be by December of 2020,
then January, certainly by January 6th, then by
January 20th, Inauguration Day, then it would be
by March or April. Trump was going to be back. It
was going to be late spring. It was going to be
early summer. It was going to be August of 2021.
Then it was going to be Thanksgiving 2021.
Do you think that pillow even believes this?
I have to tell you, from what people are telling
me who know this guy personally, people in the
media and whatnot, he really seems to be off the
off the rails. Completely off the rails. And he
may actually believe this stuff. And it doesn't
seem to be untrue that this entire thing flying
around the country with the machines.
Speaker 4: Doing a class action
lawsuit against all machines.
Speaker 1: Speaking at the rallies, it genuinely
seems to have ruined his relationship with his
family. So I'm increasingly of the mindset that
he does believe it. Let me know what you think. We
have a fantastic membership program for The David
Pakman Show. We do an extra show every day for
our members and all it takes to get access is to
sign up at join Packman dot com. That's it takes
about a minute for someone of average computer
computer with average computer proficiency.
You can use the coupon code big voting 22. If
you would like a discount. And then every single
day you'll get the bonus show and you'll get the
commercial free audio and video feed of the show.
It's a beautiful thing. The David Pakman Show is a
viewer supported program, which depends on support
from not other people, but people like you,
people who might watch a clip on YouTube or listen
to a podcast or watch us on TV or listen on the
radio. You can sign up for a membership at join
PAC Mint.com and you can use the coupon code, not
mandatory, but available. You can use the coupon
code. Big voting 22 to get yourself a discount.